Oh God I messed up everything it show's
over we're done that's like 30 pounds of
s'mores right here welcome back to
tasties making a big this is the show
where I make giant food for my friends
and special guests today I've invited in
Quinta Brunson you might know her from
BuzzFeed videos from her show hair flick
and from her HBO series a black lady
sketch show she's super awesome and I
really want to see if I can impress her
with a giant version of something so
let's go meet her
so Quinta good well I know that a lot of
people are excited to see you here today
they've probably been following you you
know watching all the stuff did at
BuzzFeed I do want to know though what
is your relationship with food uh so I
love to eat it I don't think that's
unique cooking it frightens me terrifies
me I have this fear of killing people
I'm just now starting to get over it I'm
starting to cook a lot more and
experiment with it but that fear is
still there I mean cooking I will say it
can be dangerous it can be dangerous and
then it has to taste good after all of
it I kind of wish that people went in
judge food if it didn't taste good like
I went through a lot of work if it
didn't taste good just live with it I
don't know if you know I've actually
been challenged by a fellow a tasty
producer name's reate and she wanted a
giant marshmallow but I was like why
don't we take that one step further and
I wanted to see if I can make a giant
s'mores okay that sound okay not a man
cooking for me I don't care what you
make okay all right sounds good sequence
[Music]
well this is Rhea
you probably already know her she's the
host and producer out make it fancy
she's been on worth it she's gonna
eating your feet is pretty much taking
over Internet so I'm very honored to
have you on the show yeah but you don't
say best twice if you know I heard you
talk a little smack I in some of your
previous videos I love a tune I wish it
was my pillow I miss you I'll be making
big for me you know I can't really back
down from a challenge like that so we're
gonna make a giant s'mores today what's
the first step we gonna make giant
graham cracker hmm I've made a graham
cracker before you never made a giant Oh
we'll see okay first we gonna mix dry
ingredients okay all-purpose flour whole
wheat and sugar baking powder good job
thank you I'll mix this and you'll work
on the wet ingredients yes so canola oil
honey how does this look to you is that
pretty good
yeah okay so I'm going to fall over
almost like a construction lon
why is it like construction work have
you made of cement before no I think we
might have to use our hand
okay all right gloves on all right this
is so sad it's like what sand
oh he's getting tougher oh my god no
this is how you get your mouth off like
I need to go to the gym more just so I
can be ready for this very whoa oh I
don't think that's legal
those things away you need a like
Sequoia 'they are doing like like lucky
Oh like a trade
[Music]
okay so is this good yeah yeah right
alright we're gonna take this into the
fridge so it can rest all right bye-bye
well I mean I made this guy in the back
well this guy was hanging out so what do
we have to do so we are going to roll it
all and are we gonna use two parchment
paper as a guide basically I want to
make this sighs it's tricky yeah you
need something else to help you I need
some Elvis yeah but why does it have to
be Elvis I don't know what you did in
here when you're a pastry chef yeah hi
hi al oh yeah Heights impels laid off so
this is pretty good do you want to get
into the tray now yes I think we have to
help each other all right that's what
best friends do right yeah yes sorry
ready one two three go nice
right I think it looks good yeah your
looks nicer than mine thank you yeah
okay so now the signature thing about
the graham crackers are the holes what's
our strategy are you gonna use giant
pork and you want to do at first I can
follow you yes you're cool so what are
the holes do it prevents expanding too
much
so that's a puffed-up okay cool
combined ray and I have created 1,200
holes let's go bake these graham
crackers no baked out really well it
smells great I think it's time to make a
giant marshmallow I want to borrow a
technique that I used in my 100 layer
lasagna video where you make walls out
of foil and you reinforce them with dry
lasagna noodles I think we'll use maybe
like seven by four lasagna noodles huh
you can lay these about like a
centimeter apart we're gonna do is we're
gonna fold it across your presses flat
and you can see or at one two three four
five six seven so this is where we break
it it'll make the poll so it's like this
this is way bigger than I've ever done
so it's kind of crazy this DIY
engineering okay oh yeah let's do that
and then we'll just go around I guess
like a snake and then BOOM tada okay
we're gonna make a giant marshmallow yes
let's start with some gelatin okay
followed by some water get it with this
whisk attachment you also have to make
like a hot sugar make sure that we can
whip later so let's turn on these about
a high heat
I like how synchronized we are corn
syrup man let's both water yeah vanilla
let's give this a stir so we're adding
sugar and corn syrup because you know
when you're working with sugar
temperatures very important I'm sure
you'd know that you can take it you know
like five degrees up five degrees down
and suddenly the texture totally changes
so the chorus here was almost like a
safety net or like it doesn't
immediately go crazy let's turn on these
mixers and make some marshmallow yeah
all right so we can go slow
this is very hot sugar please don't try
this at home I think we were gonna take
a scoop of this and slowly stream it
into this wall it is going what's the
difference between making a fresh
homemade marshmallow and just like
eating the ones you eat on the package I
feel like it's tastier I feel like it's
less sugary and I feel like it's more
Airy yeah the sugar is at 240 so it's at
the softball stage so by whipping air
into it you're doing thousands of little
air bubbles that cause the fluffiness of
a marshmallow and you're also cooling it
so that the sugar sets that it makes
sure that the marshal gets it's bouncy
so we turn it up a bit all the sugar is
in it smells amazing transformations
crazy I know just want to squeeze it
yeah
so these are ready turn it off turn it
up okay so let's get these out okay
whoa on three we're gonna pour into here
okay one two three
like doggy-paddling it what's the next
Oh
so next well we got to get this big ball
into our big wall situation we have back
there oh my god okay spray the walls to
the marshmallow to the stick mmm-hmm oh
sorry sorry
ready three two one the walls are
holding all right Wow sorry I don't
clean it up right now
Adams pissed oh god I messed up
everything it show us over we're done
so that ported really nice powdered
sugar
you know marshmallows you coated in
powdered sugar so they don't stick when
you cut them yeah whoa make it rain
you're doing great this looks amazing
I just can't wait to cut into it okay so
this it's really hot sugar and I think
we need to let it cool okay
Oh what's rolling around loopy beep so
we're gonna make a giant chocolate bar
yeah what kind of setup is this so we
are boiling the water and we are going
to put bulb over melt chocolate sure
bubble bath and so it's like a slower
more even heat okay first we gonna you
it's like half over the tripod shape
okay and then I'm adding coconut oil so
this is like a pop is eight pounds so
each chocolate chip weighs about one
gram or less and there are 454 grams in
pound so eight pounds of chocolate is
3632 chocolate chips if this giant
chocolate bar that we're making your
true agent yeah I'm not really helping
the stereotype how about I hold this
while you do your stuff yeah sure I want
you to use both because it's metal reas
concern for my safety
don't die under my watch she is my best
friend there's no emotion with that line
the chocolates melted so please add the
other bowl you're like Willy Wonka
you're an open-loop well really won't
well you're really won't go that sounds
about right
oh yeah what's next are you gonna pull
over so we can wait giant chocolate bar
all right let's do it
get in there okay you can do it okay
hold you create said I can do it here we
go
[Music]
almost got it over this side I'm just
gonna hold the bowl here gonna scoop out
and if you miss any I'll just eat the
rest don't worry about it okay just look
at the ball all right oh we doing that I
was a hostage okay
I wasn't look Wow beautiful and you
magically got no chocolate look at your
apron look at mine I have flour sugar
and chocolate all over my apron Rhea is
looking I'm a fancy lady that you are
very insulated for to set into chocolate
bar with the cool it right yes let's try
two together see guys time to assemble
we have two fully baked graham crackers
cooled a marshmallow that's inside the
walls and a really
really nice solid chocolate bar can we
just like kind of flip it on to it you
know if that works you want to give me
some moral support okay that'd be great
whoa whoa Alvey yeah yes okay cool
nice oh it's good firm crust snow so
there's a lot of extra sugar maybe we
brush that this way first oh you know
when I was in New York
oh my favorite things to do what after
snow I'll make snow snowman but instead
of making face oh just print your face
create tsunami look like you three give
Quinta we should plan our faces I'll
think of something oh okay whoa oh
that's so cool mochi yeah hmm that's
good so what's next
okay well you requested a giant
marshmallow and so do you have a special
present yeah yeah give me one second
yeah I got the culinary team to make you
another marshmallow yeah because I know
how much you wanted to use it as a giant
pillow so how about I hold it up and you
can lay your head against it
it's like a memory foam creamy farm back
to business
thank you I think we'll just get in here
okay yeah let's try just get out okay
get dirty
we're just gonna transport it over okay
almost yeah and then go go go go go
okay it's coming out what's the best
part about a s'mores reate poaching
fortune fire yeah I'm gonna wash our
hands we're gonna get to the fun for me
hey high five
I already called it crashing bird baby
whoo
I'm using to blow torches every a is
using an attachment called the Sears all
Omar's getting course you have a secret
message to clean up maybe trolley got
hearts yeah that's pretty much it I
think we did a great job yeah okay so
the chocolate goes on next right yeah
how do we do
no no it's okay let's bring it over here
and see don't break don't break don't
break yeah okay and then we're gonna go
down right there yeah Wow nice the final
layer we have to put on the cracker
don't break it
I think I have some special tools
that'll make this possible one second
Sabri a what is a pizza peel over there
and then you let go
[Music]
great job that's my god yeah I was wild
that's like 30 pounds of s'mores right
here Wow
I feel exhausted I think it looks
amazing yeah I think the proportions are
correct the chocolate is melted the
marshmallows toasted and actually really
want to eat it but we have to go get
Quinta first yes keep going keep going
keep going
well Quinto we have a giant s'mores okay
in front of you so on the count of three
open your eyes
one two three it's just silly yeah
they're regular size right you know
we'll get out don't worry this is worth
my weight it is more this is ridiculous
how we also have some big milk for you
oh my god Danny how should we oh you
guys are all that thank you god this is
like I think it's the chocolate your
fingers yes ma'am sure sure I don't know
how to
oh it's a lot to handle so the
practicality of eating this is not very
high as you can see let me take a
workout class today but I'm doing this
instead yeah thank you my mother is
gonna reach through the screens badly
about you right now we're gonna share
this with all the employees waiting
downstairs thank you for coming on the
show thank you for having me yeah I
appreciate it chocolate way by hands did
it I'm very happy with the way it turned
out like physically and how I look and
how he built it but probably not the
most practical thing that brings her
Christmas party if you want to press a
lot of guests I would say yeah thank you
for make my dream come true of course
anytime and thank you for helping me
make your dream come true great job
really yeah and if you guys want us to
make any more giant fruits together
you'll let us know until next time
[Music]